[Musique]
oui mais la parole de m6 et sa maladie
puis alors cette semaine je veux
partager avec vous un fait qui m'est
arrivé la dernière journée qui était
très malheureux mais qui a allumé ans
devant moi quand même quelque chose qui
est très personnel et très important
c'est à dire je commence par le début je
me réveille un matin je vois un post sur
facebook qui se pose est un fait
historique qui a été publiée par musée
et ce fait historique est vraiment
facile a contredit ainsi non on va
commenter et je fais ce que je dis à
tout le monde
lisez pas les commentaires geely les
commentaires puis je vois énormément de
commentaires biaisé dînatoire ou même
carrément racistes envers les
communautés autochtones et
l'interprétation est très grave on était
les banques alors c'est quand même venu
chercher chez moi quelque chose de très
différent pas juste parce que c'était
impose sur l'histoire de programmation
pas juste parce qu'il y avait des
commentaires très très très biaisée
au-dessous de ce poste mais aussi parce
que la pratique nous est alors monté
loin je dors j'ai commencé ma première
emploi était au musée de bainghen un
petit musée site d'interprétation mais
qui a eu un impact énorme parce qu'après
j'ai travaillé au musée
naomi zone nature qui le jardin
botanique j'en ai marre nation et
ensuite au musée mais quoi ça c'est des
premiers emplois que j'ai eues en
arrivant à montréal
je suis aujourd'hui encore sur le ca le
conseil d'administration du musée mccord
parce que justement mon expérience est
extrêmement positive parce que j'ai vu
des pratiques musicales qui transformait
qui était déjà très actif à bord à la
réconciliation
et donc ça me fait de voir aussi par le
passé l'importance une pratique muséal
qui est en inde et respectueuse et je
vous dis ce que je fais constamment avec
7 prenaient que c'est d'amener des faits
d'histoire ou de le mélanger avec le
quotidien devant comment on peut
interpréter d'histoire pour pouvoir
amener la voie des premières nations
cependant avec se pose là je vois pas en
tout la voix des programmations
puisqu'après avoir
déposer mes commentaires je reviens et
je vois que mes commentaires ont toutes
été effacées et que j'étais bloqué de la
page c'est certain que j'étais vraiment
outrée mais j'étais aussi quelqu'un qui
avait partagé et beaucoup de demandes la
communauté des revenus pour pouvoir
mettre leurs commentaires le mmm est
systématiquement les commentaires de la
communauté et des alliés autochtone
était facile et les commentaires
problématique du début étaient laissés
sur place
donc j'ai fait ce que je fais toujours
raisonnablement voir quoi
et j'ai contacté le musée j'ai fait une
recherche sur le musée aussi d'ailleurs
et pour me rends compte que c'est un
très petit musée physiquement qui est
tenu par une seule personne
j'ai pas purement plus de détails car
quand j'ai téléphoné pour demander
justement pourquoi est ce que vous
laissez les commentaires racistes sur
place je raccroche au nez en me donnant
à moi je suis la conversation finit là
on peut pas forcer le dialogue
cependant comporte le type de musique ou
de site d'interprétation
on a une responsabilité comme the spider
man avec des grands pouvoirs viennent
des grandes responsabilités et un musée
pour moi des normes pour un musée c'est
comme dire je porte le nom de champagne
et là je me faisais face à un vin
mousseux
mais ça n'empêche pas que il ya un code
2d aux deux légions muséologie et ce
code de déontologie pour moi s'applique
à tout le monde qui porte ce titre là
donc on peut pas faire de la
discrimination envers une communauté on
peut pas faire une interprétation qui
nuit à la communauté et on n'a même pas
pu porter notre voix pour dire on n'est
pas d'accord avec ce fait d'histoire et
certaines personnes andy roddick avait
opposé un fait est ce parce qu'un
histoire humaine peu fait l'histoire et
c'est un fait qui est une histoire donc
c'était raconter s'est transférée de
bouche à oreille ou par texte et par
écrit
donc l humain entre ce qui s'est passé
et les personnes qui va entendre le fait
qu'il va pas c'est d'ailleurs par
l'amour je laissais personnes qui votent
à l'interpréter donc l'interprète ou le
musée cette responsabilité-là vient
aussi avec un devoir de toujours se
mettre à jour des mises à jour constante
chez les personnes comme dans les
musiques puisque c'est pour toi qui
décide que
exposition va avoir lieu quel sujet va
être mis de l'avant et souvent corps le
sujet de change dans un musée comme une
exposition change se retrouve à faire
une recherche et une étude sur un sujet
complètement différente des intérêts
personnels
donc je deviens plus comme la personne
qui va décider comment l'histoire de
cette exposition la va se dérouler une
femme autochtone qui raconte l'histoire
d'une exposition d'octobre
voilà raconte et demande aux québécois
ou d'une québécoise qui vont faire la
même interprétation mais avec une
solution avec un regard différent et
pareillement si par exemple moi je m'en
réfère l'interprétation je sais pas moi
de la vie des pêcheurs de crabes genre
un point de vue très différents de
quelqu'un qui était carrément sur un
bateau ceci dit on peut pas interpréter
l'histoire juste à la saveur que l'on
veut lui donner ou au goût qu'on veut
lui donner faut trouver dans les faits
historiques lèche les points d'intérêt
les points de contention les il faut
écouter les deux points de vue
d'ailleurs de même des fois trois points
de vue ça me rappelle certains débats
sur la laïcité que j'ai eu par le passé
parce que les points de vue il y en a
beaucoup et des interprétations c'est à
dire comment on regarde un fait
historique à 360° vont transformer aussi
comment on voit la raconter ensuite au
grand public mais pour moi le rôle de
l'interprète de route du musée le rôle
du site d'interprétation c'est souvent
la première rend compte qu'un enfant une
famille que l'individu part à voir avec
son histoire avec l'histoire de
quelqu'un dont donc la responsabilité
est énorme et l'impact d'une exposition
de musique peut avoir un effet
transforme à part chez un individu
donc je pense juste - apprendre en jeu
d'aller voir l'exposition sur frida
kahlo ça va transformer sa transformer
probablement mon interprétation des
peintres femmes au dr anne agressif il y
avait ça ouvrait d'ailleurs un point de
vue une fenêtre sur un regard que je
n'avais jamais vu parce que moi j'avais
vu beaucoup d'artistes blanc européen
mais là je voyais un regard qui est des
plus proches du
et ça ça a changé ma vie donc pour moi
l'impact de musée un parc de
l'interprétation de l'histoire c'est une
responsabilité et on doit la respecter
alors je vous ai d'ailleurs pendant le
confinement à visiter les musées parce
qu'ils ont de plus en plus une présence
virtuelle en ligne importante est
incroyable je me sers d'ailleurs
beaucoup des collections en ligne
énuméré pour retrouver des outils ou des
objets qui venait de l'histoire des
premières nations des communautés et
nous pour pouvoir voir j'ai physiquement
de quoi vers les objets que mes ancêtres
utilisez donc je vous invite sincèrement
vous intéresser au musée respecter leur
travail et surtout à ne pas la dévier de
son rôle de réconciliation surtout si on
dit qu'on est un site d'interprétation
de la culture autochtone et québécoise
il faut écouter une partie des voix que
vous représentez d'or vos expositions et
pas les effacer
puisque les meilleures pratiques musée
elle se transforme constamment alors je
souhaite une belle semaine et j'espère
que vous avez partagé une vidéo et vous
envoyer toutes vos questions à l'espèce
autochtone